thank you
[Music]
well he's like 17 times
industry
now
how do you think I keep a score
foreign
[Music]
thank you
um
opportunity
the house will come to order members
take your seats please
[Music]
questions
members take your seats
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who moves
with the house adjourned from the
session of June 8th
2023. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
all those opposed name the eyes have it
and the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
house chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart
pastor of Saint Paul's United Methodist
Church in Manchester
good morning Mr Speaker
and and Mr Speaker step in
good morning House of Representatives
let us be in a spirit of Prayer
good morning almighty God
in this world full of noise
help us to find your calm
in this world full of violence
help us to find your peace
in this world full of being lost
help us to find your compass to guide us
in this world full of fear
help us to find courage in you
in this world full of hate
help us to find love
through you
in this world full of loneliness
help us to find your community
in this world full of hopelessness
help us to find you
and in this world full of grieving
help us to feel your embrace
God we continue to ask that you be with
all those that might be grieving the
loss of a friend or a loved one this day
we ask that you continue to hold
representative Joseph jambren and his
immediate family as they continue their
Journey
let the jandarin family know
his family that is gathered here today
pray that they may be comforted knowing
that their loved one is resting in your
loving arms
oh God I ask that you blessed This House
of Representatives today as they begin
their work for the great people of this
great state
guide them in the debate process
guide them in the listening process
guide them in the decision process
o loving and gracious God
we give you all the glory to all the
work we do this day
and it is in you we give our thanks and
praise
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
Merrimack representative Tim McGruff who
will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
the chair recognizes Miss Olivia said
Silas of Windham who will now sing our
national anthem
[Music]
by the dawn's early
light what's so proudly we
had had the
twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
[Music]
or the
ramparts we were
we're so
gallantly streaming
[Music]
and the
rockets red glass
the bombs bursting in
air
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there
does that Star Spangled
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
stations
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives hatch Judy Wayne
McDonald cyber esophagitis the day
important business represented as
brewyard Gorski Mason McLean O'Hara
Sanborn Schultz Simon and Saint Claire
the day illness in the family
representative muns
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attempt to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Charlie Taylor guest of
Representative priests Dave and Mary
butt parents of Representative McCarter
The Honorable Jane Johnson former member
from Swansea and Juliana Bergeron guests
of Representative Rhodes Mark totman
guest of Representative mague and Dan
the Bears guest of Representative Morton
they are with us in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend the Senate
messages the chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs that the
house in the passage of the following
title bill with amendment in the passage
of which amendment the Senate has the
concurrence of a house house bill 584
relative to the uniform commercial codes
article on controllable electronic
records
representative hunt moves that we concur
representative Herbert is recognized to
speak against the motion
thank you Mr chair
um colleagues
I stand here to you're going to pull
that mic closure I stand here in
opposition to the concur
motion
um on 584.
and I'm I would like to quickly describe
what we're considering and I hopefully
will uh
persuade you
that the cryptocurrency
business is very dangerous
and I I would think that we would not
endorse it
um
what I'm going to read well I read
quickly so don't worry about the time on
it
I'm going to read somebody's Dennis
Kelleher is co-founder of better markets
this was published in May 11 2023
and this is a description of somebody
who actually knows banking
and I'm sure understands cryptocurrency
far better than most people in this room
um
let's talk about crypto some have been
saying that crypto is dead now
we obviously know it's not but as you
point out there are lots of people still
pushing it including politicians
can you explain the relationship between
crypto and the banking
crisis
the entire crypto industry is by choice
this is his answer the entire crypto
industry is by choice
and design a largely Lawless industry
it's built on what they want to claim is
a financial innovation
but it's not really an innovation it's
just a new version of what the financial
industry has been doing for decades and
decades
which is coming up with different ways
to uh
offer and sell Financial products that
are either Securities or commodities
uh yet the crypto industry is claiming
oh no we're not a security and commodity
we're special new and unique and we want
special new and unique treatment and
laws
what they really want is as few
regulations and laws as possible as they
can use what is fundamentally a
predatory business model
to rip people off
one of the reasons
one of the reasons we don't have any uh
have an even worse
this came after the collapse of several
banks by the way so that's the timing of
it
uh
let's see I lost my place the reasons we
don't have even worse financial crash
right now is because the banking
regulators
and other Regulators have done a pretty
good job of
preventing crypto from getting
interconnected with the core of the
banks banking system up until now the
crypto industry has really been running
parallel to the core of the legitimate
Financial system and it has
and it has not been interconnected
certainly not as much as the industry
has been attempting to do over the last
several years the problem is not just a
lawless industry but a lawless industry
that's making a lot of money
and using hundreds of millions of
dollars in campaign contributions and
lobbying to buy elected officials and
other allies
like academics trade groups and the
media they've engaged in a massive
lobbying campaign to get their special
interest put above the public interest
nothing illustrates that more than the
fact that the crypto lost around 80 to
90 percent of its value in less than a
year
and the mo and the Marquee names in the
industry have turned out to be frauds or
criminals
given that it should have been consigned
to the Dustbin of history but yet you
have all these elected officials
almost entirely but not only Republicans
this is him seeking
the concur motion by the way that I'm
opposing is from the Democrat Party
just to make that clear
just recently criticizing Regulators for
protecting investors consumers in the
financial system it's hard to understand
but for the amount of money they have
spent to capture Washington to hijack
the agenda and to elevate their special
interests above the public interest
why is crypto so dangerous to the public
interest to ordinary investors the
crypto industry is engaged in the offer
and sale of Securities and commodities
but they don't want to follow the rules
and laws that apply to every other
legitimate business in the United States
when they offer to sell Securities and
commodities the core investor consumer
and financial stability protections
so for example if you want to be a
broker dealer or a Clearinghouse or an
exchange that deals in Securities and
commodities in the United States you
have to register with the cftc I think
that's the Commodities Commodities
Financial
it's a Chicago outfit or the SEC you
have to file periodic reports they come
into your business to make sure that you
are doing things like keeping customers
assets segregated that you are not
misusing customers assets exactly FTX
and Sam bankman Freed's criminal
Enterprise show the rot at the core of
the end of the crypto industry in one
business unit they went they want to
have an exchange a broker dealer a
Clearinghouse a hedge fund and a
property trading shop offering
Securities and other services to the
public but without any of the
regulations to eliminate for example
conflicts of interest or that require
them to know their customer and prevent
things like money laundering which is in
the history of crypto where crypto
actually came from
uh every other legitimate Financial
business in the United States follows
these very basic investor and customer
protections and underlying these are
very important stability protections but
crypto says well
we don't want to because we're special
and we're different and they are quite
different
the only way they're different is that
crypto has been around for 14 years and
has no legitimate or socially useful
purpose
the only thing it has proof so far is
that it's good for is ransomware money
laundering tax evasion funding
narco-terrorists and Rogue States and
other illegal activities
which is why all the trading is offshore
and yet it was billed as the promise of
democrat democratizing Finance it was
supposed to help regular people Achieve
Financial equality to allow people of
color to climb the economic ladder
the exact opposite has happened as we
have seen over and over again for
decades when somebody is claiming to be
in the business of democratizing Finance
helping communities of color and helping
poor people it's almost always the
opposite
that's crypto many have lost lots of
money that they couldn't afford to lose
and that money that money which adds up
to billions and billions of dollars
lines the pockets of these crypto Crux
one study showed that somewhere in the
neighborhood of 60 to 70 percent of
crypto transactions are done by people
with annual incomes of fifty thousand
dollars or below
they're being sold a marketing Ploy of
great riches and low risk which is not
true
I could go on
but the fact of the matter is
the fact of the matter is that I'm what
I'm trying to warn you all of is that
the crypto industry is to say the least
not a good idea to embrace
we have a banking system we have
essentially a digital currency all
already called the dollar
and it it's it's uh I think it's about
55 percent of every uh reserves held in
the in capital banks in in National
Banks around the world so we're we're in
very good shape we don't need another we
know we don't need another currency
and um so I just hope that you
put the final bullet in this BEAST's
head and and not concur with the
Democrat uh it said minor minor
differences and when I ever see that in
a in a statement with legislation in it
I always know it's anything but
so
thanks for listening to me
representative Hunters recognized to
speak briefly in support of the motion
thank you very much Mr Speaker in all
due respect to our one member committee
who is opposed to this legislation uh
the rest of the committee is in support
of this amendment and we do hope you
will concur thank you
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
chair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendments in the
passage of which amendments the Senate
has concurrence of the house house bill
46 establishing a committee to study
replacement of bail Commissioners with
court magistrates and relative to
delinquent payment of accounts by an
on-premises and off-premises licensees
and relative to electronic payments to
employee debit cards
the question is on the motion to
Representatives Weiler and Roy move that
we non-concur representative Roy is
recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the committee non-concurs on
the change to the bill because they
added
a part to do with how employees are
going to get paychecks in the form of
debit cards and
um
first of all we didn't consider that
really appropriate to put on this
criminal justice Bill and second of all
we really couldn't figure out how an
employee would be able to get all of his
money if he for example or she had 58
cents left how do you how do you get
that out of there uh tell our machine
won't give you 58 cents and what happens
to the money after so long does it go
back to the company where does it go and
you start talking about tens of
thousands of people that's an awful lot
of money that may go back to the company
it just the bill didn't have a public
Hearing in the house it's very
complicated it affects people's
livelihoods and how they get their money
and I would ask the house to um
agree with the committee and vote to
support our non-concur
the question is on the motion soon
non-concur you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those suppose nay the eyes have it
emotions adopted
chair recognizes a clerk for further
Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs the house
and the pastor of the following title
bill with the men in the passage of
which amendment the Senate acid
concurrence of the house house bill 97
establishing an additional penalty for a
violation of privacy
representative Roy moves that we concur
is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker the committee moves
that we concur on this bill the Senate
made changes very small and they were
actually helpful it made it so that on a
second Offense for this
no matter where you were charged in the
country it would count as a second
offense in New Hampshire instead of just
a second offense in New Hampshire which
as which is what we passed so it was a
helpful ad in this case and I would ask
you to support our concur motion thank
you
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nay the eyes have it
and the motion was adopted the chair
recognizes the clerk before the Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate occurs at
the house and the passage of the
following entitled bill with amendment
that passes which amendment the Senate
has concurrence of the house has Bill
287 removing Fentanyl and xylazine
testing equipment from the definition of
drug paraphernalia in the controlled
Drug Act
representative Roy moves that we Concur
and is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker the committee moves
to concur on this motion because
um what that what was added was very
helpful
um it's very important that we not only
be allowed to test for fentanyl but
xylazine is a horrific drug that's
making its way or has made its way into
our
um into our systems and state and it
causes horrific damage as people use it
fentanyl is dangerous enough as it is
this causes horrific wounds
um that that you can't recover from it's
horrible
personally for me I voted to support
this because as a parent I want access
to these so if I find something in my
child's possession I want to know what
he's or she is dealing with and I think
just from a parent's perspective it's
important it's all from a public safety
perspective very important that people
can go somewhere and get a test done to
make sure they know what they're dealing
with it's bad enough that they have this
horrible disease that they're addicted
to
the least we can do is to start to make
sure that they're not being poisoned in
addition to the horrific substances
they're already trapped with so uh
chameleon asks that you would support
our motion to concur
the questions on the motion to concur
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those opposing a the
eyes have it and the motion is adapted
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs the house and the passage
of the following title bill with
Amendment the passenger which amendment
the Senate concurrence of the house
house bill 421 relative to providing
menstrual hygiene products at no cost to
individuals who biologically menstruate
in state and County correctional
facilities
representative Roy moves
representative Roy
moves that we concur representative Rose
is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues a few weeks ago I came in
front of you and we made a motion to
table a bill that was very similar to
this and the reason was because we had
sent very strong very agreeable language
over to our friends over there and we
asked you to table it because in the
event that they
screwed up the bill we could at least
have a chance to fix it and the good
news is is they actually made some
changes to their bill and these are all
very agreeable there's just one thing
that we did not get that we requested
and the sponsor is going to work on that
and bring it back next time around so
please concur
the questions on the motion to concur
are you ready ready what
okay you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
hello supposed name
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the following
title bill with Amendment the pastor
which amendment the Senate has to
concurrence of the house house bill 349
relative to a special purpose school
district for Bridgewater Hebron and
Groton
representative Ladd moves that we Concur
and is recognized speaker's motion
thank you very much Mr Speaker I
HP 349 deals with the Special School
District of Hebron Groton and
Bridgewater pulling out from Newfound
school uh Newfound Area School District
this bill was submitted by the Senate to
reflect language which better defines
the procedure in the process in a
timeline involved in this process the
amending language put forth by the
Senate is fair well defined and fiscally
responsible to all those within the
school district that exists right now so
please support this legislation
questions on the motion to concur are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those opposed nay the
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs that the house and the
passion of falling entitled bill with
amendment in the pastor which amendment
the Senate asking currents of the house
house bill 492 requiring the Department
of Education to provide the House and
Senate standing committees responsible
for Education with copies of the laws
and rules relative to education
Representatives Ladd and Weiler move
that we concur representative Ladd is
recognized to speak thank you very much
Mr Speaker the Senate amended this bill
by putting seven new words into the bill
the Senate has stated that these
materials these rules and statutes will
be available to the Senate and House
Education committees pursuant to the
other words at the request of the
committee chairs
so with that I ask you to concur
the questions on the Motions to concur
you're ready for the question all those
in favor say aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs that the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house house bill 244 relative to
the delivery of absentee ballots
representative Berry moves that we
Concur and is recognized to speak to his
motion
our friends on the other side of the
wall made minor grammatical changes it's
a good Bill thank you
the questions on the motion should
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposing a the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted the chair
recognizes the clerk for further Senate
messages Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the house and the pastor of the
Fong title bill with an amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
has the concurrence of the house house
bill 337 relative to directing the
office of professional life insurance
certification to provide notice of
public meetings and an opportunity for
comment from the public and creating a
new attorney to position
Representatives McGuire and Weiler move
that we concur representative McGuire is
recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker when we heard this
bill which deals with making sure all
the professional boards publish their
agendas and have the material needed for
the meeting available in advance
we heard there might be a cost impact
but we didn't really get any definition
of it
when it got to the Senate they looked
further into the cost impact and adds
one one person and it clarifies that
it's to keep
the
private and personal information that
some of the boards deal with from being
disseminated we do want to disseminate
all of the public information but we but
not the non-public information
and if we want that we have to pay for
it so the committee agreed to Concur and
I hope you do also
the questions on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
for further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs at the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has a concurrence
of the house house bill 384 FNA relative
to building a new legislative parking
garage and making an appropriation
therefore renaming the capital project
overview committee and establishing The
Joint legislative parking garage
oversight Commission
representative Weiler moves that we
concurrent is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker this bill speaks to
funding the legislative parking garage
it includes moving costs Demolition and
building of the new one
the house amended it to have a a new
committee that would be called the
capital project overview committee which
would meet several times a year
additionally there was a joint
legislative
parking garage oversight committee that
would meet a couple of times a year
when it went to the Senate they The
Joint legislative parking garage
oversight committee was
six members of the House four members of
the Senate
and a few others and the Senate added
two people to that legislative parking
garage oversight committee they added
the Chief Operating Officer of the
general court some of you may know Terry
puff and a member of this appointed by
the city of Concord I move that we
concur
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye aye all those opposed
nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
for further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs the house and the
passage of the falling entitled bill
with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate asks the
concurrence of the house has Bill two 38
relative to the role of quality control
and the developmental disability service
system
representative Leon moves that we Concur
and is recognized to speak to her motion
thank you Mr Speaker we recommend
concurrence on this bill as it increases
transparency between the department and
the developmental developmentally
delayed community
sorry I needed a little more coffee this
morning between the developmentally
disabled Community this is very
important there are only some minor
changes in there and so we ask for your
concurrence
the questions on the motion should
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye all those
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is adopted the chair recognizes
the clerk for further Senate messages Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs that the
house and the passage of the Fong and
title bill with Amendment the passage of
which amendment the center has a
concurrence of the house house bill 408
relative to foster children and
vaccinations
representative Leon moves that we Concur
and is recognized speaks or emotion
speaker we recommend
currents on this bill as it treats
children who share their homes with
foster children the same way as all
other children in the state for
vaccination our friends on the other
side of the wall added a requirement for
the Department to seek a waiver and we
believe that this is appropriate we ask
for your concurrence
questions on the motion to concur you're
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those posne the guys
have it and the motion is adopted the
chair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs the house and the passage of the
following title bill with Amendment the
passage of which amendment the Senate
has a concurrence of the house house
bill 642 relative to budget flexibility
for services for the developmentally
disabled
representative Leon moves that we Concur
and has recognized to speak to a motion
Mr Speaker we recommend concurrence on
this bill as it allows the Department of
Behavioral supports the flexibility to
use unused money to meet the needs of
people in this community this is a very
very complicated top topic however this
is something that is necessary now we
believe the sen the changes made by the
other body were appropriate and we asked
for concurrence
the questions on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
for further Senate messages Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house and
the passage of the following entitled
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has concurrence of
the house house bill 308 relative to a
quorum for meetings open to the public
to include remote presence
representative Lynn moves that we Concur
and is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker uh colleagues this
uh as you may recall this this bill
deals with uh state boards only it does
not apply to county or local boards and
it permits state boards to adopt
procedures which would allow one-third
of the of the membership to be present
uh to be physically present and the rest
uh remote the only chain the only change
of any substance that the Senate made to
the to the proposal was to add language
that says remote participation it has to
be under our version it has to be the
the public has to be able to see and
hear what's going on remotely the Senate
changed that to say they also need to be
able to participate that is to ask
questions or to testify if it was an
evidential hearing it seems to me it
just strengthens the bill so I strongly
recommend that we concur
the questions on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye all those opposed nay
well we're going to do a clarification
vote on that so nobody in nobody out
members take your seats
the question is on the motion to concur
on House Bill 308 this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative Cannon
stop watching the board
representative Ford
you can't push it now
representative Cannon
all set sir of all members Presidents
had an opportunity to vote
271 having voted in the affirmative 98
in the negative the motion is adopted
Cher recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs that the
house and the passage of the following
title bill with Amendment the passage
which amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 321
FN local relative to minutes from
non-public sessions under the right to
know law
representative Lynn moves that we Concur
and is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker uh colleagues this
uh bill which which we passed previously
uh simply deals with the situation of
where uh public records have been uh
sealed for one reason or another one
legitimate reason or another uh but the
question of arises as to whether after a
period of time there's there's still a
reason for sealing and this provides
that uh that if if no determination has
been made within 10 years of the
original ceiling than the the public
body has to review it the Senate made no
substantive changes to this bill at all
it changed the language a little bit
actually to make it clearer but there's
no substantive changes so I recommend we
concur
the questions on the motion to concur
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs the house and the passage
of the following entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
to send and ask the concurrence of the
house has Bill 75 relative to the
election of Stratford County
Commissioners
representative Lynn turcott moves that
the house can occur representative
majority is recognized to speak against
the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I ask you to oppose the
motion of concur on HB 75 HB 75 was
introduced as a bill to increase the
threshold of county-owned personal
property subject to competitive bidding
it was it passed this house on the
consent calendar after unanimous vote
for municipal and County
in the body on the other side of the
wall all of the language from the bill
the original bill was replaced with a
bill relative to the election of
Stratford County Commissioners
the amended bill is nearly identical to
a bill retained in Municipal and County
HB 270 relative to the election of
Stratford County Commissioners
colleagues do not conflate the bill
before you now with the product that
will come out of the work on the
retained Bill the purpose of retaining
this billing committee is to allow the
county delegation the full Municipal and
County committee another stakeholders
the time to work through any issues and
find common ground
retaining a billing committee is a
well-established process that provides
significantly significantly more
opportunity to create sound legislation
than by merely adding what is for all
intent and purpose a non-germaine
Amendment this committee can get input
from the Secretary of State on the
suggestion that the amended Bill
represents redistricting outside of the
prescribed the senior redistricting
process the committee can discuss the
risks of creating a precedent whereby
Commissioners districts could be redrawn
at any time by any party
the committee will investigate the
history of why Stratford County enjoys a
unique local control of electing their
Commissioners at Large
the committee will analyze the timing of
resetting the election cycle of
Commissioners and the potential for
expensive special elections because this
this legislation would apply to the 2024
election forcing two incumbent
Commissioners to run against one another
if no one from Stratford County sought
these changes last year when the
legislature redistricted all other
elective offices to comply with the 2020
census then I submit that we have time
for a full and Frank discussion through
the retained Bill process opposing ASB
75 now will ensure that the residents
delegation representatives and
stakeholders of Stratford County will
have the best opportunity to discuss the
election of Commissioners who will
ultimately serve their County best
please press the red button thank you
representative yeah
Mr Speaker I asked for a division vote
okay
representative windsurcott is recognized
to speak in support of his motion thank
you Mr Speaker
as you just heard the original HB 75 is
actually going to be combined into
another bill that you're going to hear
shortly
the contents of hb75 that you're voting
on now was the original HP 270 that bill
was inadvertently retained in committee
it had a full hearing
okay
you laugh but it's true
had it not been we would have already
acted on this bill
as we said the other body on the other
side of the wall took HB 270 and placed
it into 75. now I'm going to read you a
current RSA and this is about
662-4 County Commissioner districts
except for Stratford County
goes on with a little bit more and then
says the county shall be divided into
districts as follows so I'm going to
read you that first part again except
for Stratford County
Stratford county is the only County in
this state that does not have districts
for commissioners
so how has this affected Stratford
County
well I can tell you that that if you're
not a city in the county
you're almost considered second-class
citizens
towns such as Milton Middleton New
Durham
Farmington Stratford Barrington Madbury
Lee and yes even Durham
our second thoughts to the criminal
current commissioners
this bill would for the very first time
create districts
bringing Stratford County up to the same
standards as everybody else the other
nine counties in New Hampshire Equity
equality and fairness
now you may have received a email
from a lobbyist from the County
Association claiming that this was
unconstitutional
that is factually incorrect when we
first brought this bill forward we
approached the Secretary of State
and he indeed said it was
constitutional and legal as well as when
the individual on the other side of the
wall
placed the language into the spillwood
debating now
also found it legal and constitutional
we heard
several times why not last term
I can tell you about that because I was
one of the house members on the special
committee for redistricting
um we had explained at the time that the
data due to covid was delayed from uh
forget if it was six seven eight months
so we were working very diligently to
try to get that done
and at that point it was brought up in
committee to do this but it was also
decided in that committee that we would
wait until a future date because we
didn't want to muddy The Waters at that
time
now I'm going to give you an analogy of
why
every County deserves
districts for their commissioners
take your county that you're in I don't
care which county it is
and assume that all your state reps
were elected at Large
and I'm going to just pick one off the
top of my head
I'll use Hillsboro
Hillsboro has 123 reps
if you elected that entire County at
large without districts where do you
imagine the majority of those reps would
come from
could you say the large cities
and all those towns on the outskirts
of Nashua Manchester would see very very
few Representatives
if you're way out on the far-flung side
of that and towns like Peterborough
you're not going to get reps
that's why
Stratford County being the only county
that does not
have districts deserves
to be the same as every other nine
counties so I ask that you would concur
on this Bill thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 75 and this is
a division vote members please take your
seats
uh
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on
House Bill 75 this is a division vote
representative grass is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
House Bill 270 which is the non-germaine
amendment to eligibility hb75 to allow
further consideration and input from
parties in Stratford County
and if I know for the last 50 years
Stratford county has been recognized
throughout the state as well-managed and
efficient government representing
citizens and taxpayers throughout the
county with its Commissioners elected
from both parties
and many of the towns
towns for the last 20 years a town has
always been represented
if I also know that the adage of if it
ain't broke don't fix it certainly
applies here
and for I know that concurring on this
bill would open a Pandora's box of legal
challenges and possible yearly efforts
to redistrict every time control of the
legislature changed hands
if and I know that just weeks ago the
speaker remarked that history was made
in bipartisan adoption and state budget
showing bipartisanship throughout this
house
what I now vote to not concur on this
highly political redistricting effort
that would end this historic session on
a very partisan
note and would I now push the red button
representative Lynn sarcast recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill is not
in fact redistricting but a districting
of Stratford County Commission districts
for the first time
if I also know that Stratford county is
the only County in our state of New
Hampshire that does not have districts
for commissioners
if I also know
if you happen to live in a small town in
a county and not in a city
like we are you are an afterthought
and if I know that Equity fairness
common sense and representation demands
that Stratford County be afforded the
same rights as all the other nine
counties in New Hampshire what I then
support the motion to concur on the bill
before us thank you Mr Speaker
the question is on the motion to concur
if you're in favor of the motion press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
um
represent wood
[Music]
representative Perez
represent Perez I couldn't tell what
that was
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote
185 in the affirmative 188 and the
negative the motion fails
representative majority moves that we
non-concur are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those proposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
I got to be faster with this thing we'll
do a clarification vote
nobody in nobody out
and no pis
all right
the question is on the motion to
non-concur if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
together
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend the state of the vote
imagine that
185 in the affirmative 188 and the
negative
the motion fails hello
help me
Mr Speaker having voted in the
affirmative with the majority I ask that
we reconsider House Bill 75 and I urge
everybody to vote no
is
yep
representative Weber for what reason
does the member rise
having had the
I think number
number on the table
representative Weber moves the house
full 75 delayed on the table
this will be a division vote members
take their seats
foreign
Hospital 75 on the table represent
majority is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that by
tabling this bill we're still going to
take up all of the content in the retain
Bill process then please press the green
button thank you
representative Lynn sercos recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that there's a another motion
that could be made other than table
would I now press the red button to
table this bill
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 75 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
represent wood
working is it not working
you want yes or no
of all members Presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote again
186 in the affirmative 188 and a
negative the motion fails
representative turcotte moves that we
non-concur and request a committee of
conference and is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker I do support that
motion of non-concur requests Committee
of conference
the motion is to non-concur and request
a committee a conference you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
[Applause]
will do a clarification vote on that
one in no one out
foreign
we're running out of motions here but
yeah the uh the motion is to non-concur
request Committee of conference and this
is a division vote if you're in favor
press the green button opposed press the
red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative wood
foreign
okay
sorry about the delay
the house will attended the state of the
vote
188 in the affirmative 186 and the
negative the motion is adopted
on behalf of the house the chair
appoints Representatives Len turcotte
power lasalles and stavis to the
committee of conference
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs of the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate asset
concurrence of the house house bill 83
relative to County Commissioners
Authority on County buildings
representative Lynn surcott lives at the
house can occur representative comfrost
is recognized to speak against the
motion
sorry
thank you Mr Speaker and honorable
colleagues I rise in opposition of the
concur motion of HB 83.
we have three branches of government
to protect the citizens of this country
the state in our counties
but here we are relegating the
delegations responsibilities of
oversight on County expenditures
we put in place a budget for the
executive branch to follow which is our
County Commissioners
this bill allows the executive branch to
spend an additional
twenty five thousand dollars
without oversight of the delegation
which may not have been included in the
budget
and Mr Speaker if I know that
taxationist theft and this amount of
money would not have the oversight of
the delegation would I now press the red
button or for ask for a division vote
and please vote no
representative Lynn surcott has
recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker as mentioned in the
previous Bill HB 83 that we're going to
vote on now I recommend a motion to
concur is actually the
combining of three separate and very
very similar bills HP 87 HP 83 and hb75
for the most part without getting into a
lot of detail it increases the amount of
uh dollars that the County Commissioners
can put bids out repair or do things
[Music]
most of them go from five to twenty five
thousand and one of them goes from 300
to 3 000 still requires them to give an
explanation as to why they did it but it
does raise the limit and I would ask
that you concur
the motion is whether to concur with the
Senate on House Bill 83 representative
contract requested a division vote this
will be a division vote member State
receipts
clear
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 83 and this is
a division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
of all members presence and an
opportunity to vote
thou shall attended the state of the
vote
301 in the affirmative 69 and the
negative the motion is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages
Mr Speaker
the Senate occurs the house and the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendments in the passage of which
amendments the Senate has the
concurrence of the house has Bill 25A
making Appropriations for Capital
Improvements
representative McConkey moves that we
Concur and is recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker esteemed colleagues
the members on the other side of the
wall made
a couple corrections to our capital
budget
but did not add any projects in fact
removed one of our bonded items CT
school project seven million dollars
from being a bonded project to uh to
over to House Bill 2
making our build even better I would
appreciate your concurrence on House
Bill 25 as amended
the questions on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question Elizabeth
say aye all those opposed nay the eyes
have it and the motion is adopted
Mr Speaker the Senate occurs of the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment and
passenger which amendment the Senate has
the concurrence of a house has Bill 296
relative to local Authority for granting
driveway permits
representative McConkey moves that we
concur as recognized speak to his motion
thank you Mr Speaker members once again
members on the other side of the wall
took a good piece of legislation and
made a minor adjustment and I would
recommend that the members concur with
the house bill 296.
the questions on the motion to concur
you recognize for the are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposne
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
chair recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs the house and the passage of the
following title bill with Amendment and
passage of which amendment the Senate as
a concurrence of the house house bill
139 relative to hydrogen energy and
establishing a hydro advisory committee
representative votes moves that we
Concur and has recognized speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker House Bill 139 when
it was passed by this house
was a bill to remove Municipal
boundaries from the
group Municipal group host net metering
program
our colleagues on the other side of the
wall like that language so much that
they removed it from this bill and put
it in another bill
then they added new language completely
new language to this bill
that language was the language of Senate
Bill 167 which this house itl'd
about a month ago
that language creates a
advisory committee within the department
of energy
to
advise the department on matters
regarding to hydrogen as an energy
source
now the house originally objected to
that bill Senate Bill 167 because that
invite advisory committee was charged
with finding ways to investigate
taxpayer and rate payer investments in
hydrogen Energy Technologies we thought
that was inappropriate this new language
in in House Bill 139 makes no mention
of requesting these taxpayer and
ratepayer Investments
in addition it places into statute a
definition of green hydrogen and that
will allow the state to qualify for
certain federal funds
so I ask you to concur with the Senate
changes to House Bill 139 thank you
the questions on the motion to concur
with the Senate on House Bill 139 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those suppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
share recognizes the clerk for further
Senate messages Mr Speaker the Senate
concurs at the house in the passage of
the phone entitled bill with Amendment
the passage of which amendment the
center nashik appearance of the house
has Bill 233 FN relative to useful
thermal energy under the renewable
portfolio standards
representative those moves that we
Concur and is recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill 233 is a good bill to
allow
thermal energy
credits to be purchased under the
renewable portfolio standard the only
changes made by our friends on the other
side of the wall
where they changed two words in two
places the two words are satisfactory
two they change those two approved by
and they did that in two places it's a
good change I recommend that we concur
thank you
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 233 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs the house
and the passage of the following title
bill with Amendment the passage of which
amendment the Senate has the concurrence
of the house has Bill 251 relative to
the cost of compliance with disclosure
of electric renewable portfolio
standards
representative foes moves that we concur
representative rains is recognized to
speak against the motion
did I get it wrong
Reynolds sorry
you recognized
thank you Mr Speaker I make a motion to
oh
thank you Mr Speaker
apologies everyone
I Rise to oppose the motion to concur on
House Bill 251
relative to the disclosure of the cost
of compliance with the RPS
this bill would require that our
electric utilities
provide to everyone
all of their customers annually
on their December bill the average
estimated annual cost for the average
residential rate payer
of compliance with the renewable
portfolio standard
now we've had enough bills in this
session that dealt with the renewable
portfolio standard
so you all know what that is it's a
requirement that each utility get a
certain amount of the electricity that
they buy on our behalf and sell to us
from renewable sources
and I do want to remind you that
renewable energy is the only kind of
energy
resource that is native to New Hampshire
we certainly don't have any fossil fuels
within our state
so in the Science Tech and energy
committee this year every one of our
state's utilities eversource Unitil
Liberty even the New Hampshire co-op
has told us that the growth of renewable
energy most of it
installed behind the meter built with
private money with some support from the
RPS
significantly reduces daytime
electricity demand across the region
and thus lowers the market clearing
price of electricity every day saving
all rate payers money
so specific to the content of this bill
When government steps in and mandates
that private companies provide certain
specific information to every one of
their customers that information
ought to be
complete
balanced and accurate
the information provided under
HP 251 would be none of those
this bill would provide one-sided
that is incomplete information only
about the costs
and nothing about the benefits
of the RPS
because the information on the bill
a simple dollar figure labeled cost of
RPS compliance would be one-sided and
incomplete it would be misleading
it would also be inaccurate because the
figure on everyone's bill would be the
average cost to reach rate payer not a
figure specific to that rate payer
so an apartment dweller would see a
figure that's much larger than the
annual average cost and the actual cost
to them and the homeowner of a 3 000
square foot house would see a figure
that's smaller than
their actual cost
so if this bill is adopted
the New Hampshire state government would
be requiring the utilities to put
information on every rate payer's bill
at the end of the year that is both
incomplete
and thus misleading and inaccurate
and to top it off
I quote from the bill language the costs
for the utilities to provide this
information shall be recovered
from Electric customers through that
utilities distribution rates
that just doesn't seem like very good
public policy
and we should be doing better than that
so please push the red button
and vote no on concurrence with sp251
and Mr Speaker I requested division vote
representative speak
thank you Mr Speaker
our friends on the other side of the
wall made a few small changes to house
bill 251.
they clarified that the department of
energy not the Public Utilities
Commission
implements and oversees the requirements
of this bill
those changes are good changes
and I recommend that we concur with the
changes that the Senate May that the
other body made to this uh to this bill
I will also say that this house passed
this bill because it is good public
policy
people want to know what they're paying
for when they buy something
So when you buy electricity from your
utility you'd like to know exactly what
you're paying for
and this simple bill
requires that the utility tell you once
a year
approximately what you're pla paying to
comply with the renewable portfolio
standard
it's no more complicated than that
it doesn't have to be an exact number to
give you a good idea of what you're
paying
but it's important that we be
transparent
with the voters
of our state
about what state government is requiring
them
to spend money on
so I urge you to
support the original passage of House
Bill 251 and to concur with the changes
made by the Senate thank you Mr Speaker
just remember yield for a question
yes you may inquire representative
Thomas
thank you Mr speaker thank the member
for taking my question uh correct me if
I'm if I'm wrong but doesn't state law
already require the cost of this program
to be put on your electric bill anyway
except that it does it in cents per
kilowatt hours and that this bill just
merely transforms it into dollars so
people can understand it better
it's correct in fact the per kilowatt
hour cost that is displayed on your bill
gives every electric bill rate payer the
opportunity to calculate the exact cost
that he's spent over the course of the
year if he desires to do so
thank you for the question
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 251
representative Reynolds has requested a
division vote this will be a division
vote members take receipts
questions whether concur with the
senator on House Bill 251 and this is a
division of a representative Corman is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that
misleading and incorrect information is
worse than no information and that the
amount that would be on the bill is
incorrect and misleading unless a
customer has exactly the average amount
over the entire state
and if I know that the information
presented is only about the cost of the
renewable portfolio standard and nothing
about the benefits would I then press
the red button
against concurrent
representative Vos is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
makes your electric bill costs much more
transparent than they are currently
and if I also know that there are other
charges on your electric bill such as
the system benefits charge
where no benefits are listed on the bill
and finally if I know that the changes
to this bill that moved oversight from
the Public Utilities Commission to the
Department of energy is a necessary
Improvement to the bill
what I press the green button to concur
on this motion thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 251 and this is
a division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
185 in the affirmative 189 and the
negative the motion fails
for what reason does remember rise
let's go ahead
the motion is to non-concur
and it sounds like it'll be a division
vote a division vote all righty
members should still be in their seats
but
give anyone an opportunity to come in
[Music]
the question is on the motion a
non-concur with Senate on House Bill 251
and this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
rich
representative rich
ball members presence had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
189 in the affirmative 186 and the
negative the motion is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs the house
and the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the center has the
concurrence of the house has Bill 275
local relative to schools approved for a
school tuition program by a school board
representative Ladd moves that we
non-concur and request State Committee
of conference
kind of are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
division's been requested well this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
the question is whether to non-concur
with the Senate and request a committee
of conference
this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
everything
represent Peterson
representative Peterson
representative point
of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
3 is 63 in the affirmative 12 in the
negative the Motions adopted
I know my hearing shot but I could have
got that one right
the chair on behalf of the house
appoints Representatives aladd Oliver
Ford Miler and dry to the committee of
conference
information
the chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs that the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate asset
concurrence of the house house bill 315
prohibiting provocations based on a
victim victims actual or perceived
gender gender identity gender expression
or sexual orientation from being used as
a defense in a criminal case
representative Roy moves that we
non-concur requested Committee of
conference
representative Muse is recognized speak
against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I I was not prepared to speak
on this particular issue today because I
thought we had an agreement uh
beforehand to concur but at 9 55 this
morning we found out that a
representative who we all have a great
deal of respect for told the leadership
of our committee that he had some issues
with the language of the bill
while I understand that there are always
things that we can do to improve the
language of the bill five minutes before
the house session where we are voting on
the bill is not the time to be making
your objections known
something else that I understand is that
there should be no room for illegal
defense in New Hampshire that uses a
person's gender or sexual identity as a
reason to excuse the actions of a person
who was committed a crime against them
if you feel the same way that I do
please support the position at the house
and the position of the Senate
and vote against the motion to
non-concur with the committee of
conference so another motion can be made
to concur with the changes that the
Senate made thank you
representative Lynn has recognized speak
in support of the motion and I would
like a division vote please
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I Rise and the first thing I
want to do is apologize to you because
representative Muse is right I did raise
this issue really at the last minute and
candidly I have to tell you honestly
it's because I looked at the language
very carefully at the last minute and
saw the problem
so let me let me explain to you what the
problem is it's on the Senate version of
the bill
um and the difficulty is this first of
all I want to make it clear I have
absolutely no problem with with the
portion of the of the bill that is
designed to to eliminate the what has
been referred to I guess in the in the
committee as the gay Panic defense I
think that is entirely appropriate
but the problem is in the Senate version
it does more than that
it goes on to say
after the language dealing with
eliminating the gay Panic defense so to
speak it goes on to say
that provocation would not be recognized
and I'm quoting now if the defendant and
the and the victim dated or had a
romantic or sexual relationship so let
me explain to you what I'm talking about
and this has nothing I want to emphasize
this this has nothing to do with gender
or gender identity at all so let me try
to give you this example it has been the
law in as far as I'm I know in England
and in the United States for 500 years
that that in the example I'm about to
give you if you if you committed a
homicide you would be entitled to ask
that the homicide be reduced from murder
to manslaughter understand this is not a
defense if you Prevail on the
provocation it does not mean that you
walk away it simply means that instead
of being guilty of murder where you
could receive life imprisonment you're
guilty of manslaughter where you could
only wear the maximum sentences is 30
years
so consider this situation
and let to make it obvious what I'm
talking about let's assume
that I am a transgender person and I
have a long-standing relationship 20 30
years whatever with another transgender
person and again this could be
transgender it could be heterosexual it
could be homosexual it doesn't matter
that's the problem with this the last
Clause of the bill so I'm a transgender
person I have a long-standing
relationship with another transgender
person and I come home from work one day
and I find that the transgender person I
had a long-standing relationship with is
in bed with a third transgender person
and I kill
I kill the person that I've had the
long-standing relationship with
under the law that has existed for many
many many years
the the I as the defendant would be
entitled to ask the jury to consider
mitigation based on provocation
this would do away with that and it
makes it has nothing whatsoever to do
with the issue of eliminating the gay
Panic defense it would change 500 years
of Law and I don't think that that's
what anybody intended but that would be
what the result of this would be and
there's been an argument suggesting that
it could be interpreted that it's
somewhat ambiguous it could it perhaps
could not be interpreted that way I
frankly say having done a lot of
interpretation of statutes over my
career I don't think that that's correct
but even if it could be argued that it's
ambiguous why would we want to pass a
law that we know is ambiguous and that
could have really bad unintended
consequences why not go to the Senate
and just say this is an easy fix we just
eliminate the Clause that I quoted to
you it's a very easy fix it doesn't
change the elimination of the gay Panic
defense which I completely agree we
should do and I know that there's been
some uh some lobbyists who have
suggested that you know there would be
terrible consequences if we eliminated
the gay Panic defense that's just flat
out wrong we should do that but we this
goes too far unintentionally and for
that reason I ask that you vote for a
committee of conference thank you very
much Mr Speaker and I asked for a
division division vote
the question is whether to non-concur
request a committee a conference on
House Bill 315 this will be a division
vote members take receipts
thank you
the question is whether to request a
committee non-concur request committee
conference on House Bill 315 and this is
a division vote representative philio is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
[Music]
Mr Speaker
if
a states have adopted bills to ban the
gay Panic defense in identical form to
HB 315 including to just name a few
California Connecticut Hawaii Maine
Nevada New Jersey Pennsylvania Rhode
Island and Washington just to name a few
and their bills banned the gay Panic
defense in identical form and never once
never once has the argument raised today
been brought up in those States and
further Mr Speaker if I believe that the
states are the Laboratories of democracy
and that the results are in and all this
bill does is the gay Panic defense sent
nothing more
and finally Mr Speaker if I believe that
each of us are truly created equal
then odd I press the red button on this
motion so that a better motion can be
made thank you
representative Roy is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that I came in here this morning
having already indicated I would concur
with this bill and if I also know that I
also found out five minutes before that
there could be a legal problem and I
actually had a full head of hair when I
got here this morning
and I know that if there is any
legitimacy to the argument that the
chief executive might get advice not to
sign it would I not now take the time to
just go over it with the other body to
make sure that it will be signed and it
will go into law and there will be no
unintended consequences because if I
also know Mr Speaker that I support this
bill I worked it through the committee
and I intend to see it become law would
I now support the committee of
conference so that we can make sure we
get it right and it gets signed into law
and before the summer it is the law in
New Hampshire I ask you to support the
committee of conference thank you
the question is whether or not concur
request Committee of conference on House
Bill 315 this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
of all members Presidents had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the vote
199 and the affirmative 175 and the
negative the motion is adopted
on behalf of the house and sharepoint's
representatives Roy Rhodes Harriet
gathright and Wheeler to the committee
of conference
chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs the house
and the pastor of the following title
billed amendments in the passage of
which amendments to send an acid
concurrence of the house house bill 610
FN expanding the definition of providers
who can certify patients of the therapy
therapeutic cannabis program and
relative to release of a defendant
pending trial and relative to product
the labeling and information guide
requirements for cannabis products and
the prohibition of the sale of hemp
products containing certain levels of
THC
representative Leon moves that we
non-concur request Committee of
conference
representative Muse is recognized to
speak against the motion
thank you colleagues I rise today to
urge you to oppose the motion to
non-concur with Committee of conference
what the amendment from the other body
does is accomplish two things
first of all it takes a useful bill with
wide support that would expand
therapeutic cannabis providers and turns
it into a Christmas tree dumpster fire
it adds the full text of SB
258. SB 258 is a bill that we retained
in the criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee that this body has
never had an opportunity to vote on and
there was a very good reason for that
and that's because SB 258 as it came to
our committee was a flawed bill with
serious constitutional issues and an
even more serious price tag
would this be 252 does is create a
presumption of dangerousness that allows
a person to be accused of certain crimes
to be held without bail for up to 36
hours
now while we all can agree that there
are issues with our bail system there
are ways to go about fixing these issues
and fixing them in an amendment like
this is not the way to do it
the judicial system estimates SB 252
which is the language incorporated into
this bill now would lead to an
additional 3 500 bail hearings
in a system where we already have a
shortage of Judges this is a number that
would require the hiring of four
additional judges and four additional
Court assistance at an unbudgeted cost
of close to five million dollars over
the next three years
on top of that it would also increase
the cost for the individ for the
Indigent defense system as well as
Transportation costs for sheriffs
because we need a way of getting people
back and forth to all of these
additional hearings and we and all of
those people are also going to need uh
representation and some of them are
Indigent so they're going to require
Indigent services
on top of that there's the fact that the
current law already allows the court to
detain any individual pre-trial
the current law also allows prosecutors
to challenge any release order that the
court disagrees with
so instead of allowing the court to
assess the facts in an individual case
this bill the way that it's written
would eliminate the Court's discretion
and replace it with a mandatory
one-size-fits-all approach
despite these flaws the criminal justice
and Public Safety Committee decided to
retain this bill as part of a good faith
effort to try to fix it over the summer
as part of an overall bipartisan effort
to put all of the proposed solutions to
New Hampshire's troubled bail system on
the table so we can actually fix them in
a systemic way
what the other body is doing by
attaching SB 252 to a perfectly good
bill is trying to impose its will on the
house by imposing a solution on us and
our constituents that is simply not
ready for prime time
please give genuine bail reform a chance
and give the criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee the chance to do the
bipartisan problem solving we all have
agreed to do over the summer
please vote no on this motion thank you
representative Leon's recognized speak
in support of the motion
colleagues I stand here before you today
to explain why House Bill 610 should
have the opportunity to proceed to a
committee of conference the underlying
Bill seeks to fix the unintended
discrimination against certain Health
Care Providers and their patients
regarding access to therapeutic cannabis
today there are 89 patients in the
program with glaucoma and not a single
one of them was certified by their
optometrist because optometrists aren't
included in the position RSA that gives
this power
if you think back to the vaccine
optometrist bill this has a similar root
issue because those four groups of
doctors are not in the position statutes
unfortunately despite House Bill 610
passing our committee unanimously and
passing on consent the other body
decided to attach two other bills and
hold these Health Care Providers and
their patients hostage
I agree with my friend from Portsmouth
about the inappropriateness of including
Senate Bill 252 on this bill
this is an issue that this body has been
dealing with this is an issue that
criminal justice plans to work on
through the fall
if we proceed to a committee of
conference
Senate Bill 252 is a non-starter within
an agreement but we need to give the
Senate the ability to back off that
Amendment and to not do a disservice to
these Health Care Providers and their
patients
there's another bill that's been
attached as well that's Senate bill 180.
that deals with some of the labeling and
educational materials and it gives some
power that already exists within the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board and explicitly puts it into law
there's another section too that a lot
of people don't want to talk about but
it doesn't I hear a lot of Rumblings
about people not liking it back in the
2018 Farm Bill there was an allowance
for hemp as long as the THC Delta 9
content was less than I think three
percent point three percent I'm not
exactly certain on that number but
basically as long as a temp where you
can't smoke it and receive the benefits
it would be allowed there's a large CBD
market and so there have been some
synthetic cannabinoids that have been
synthesized out of that those are in
grocery stores
there's definitely some labeling issues
but adding this in as an amendment on
Senate Bill 180 and then on this bill is
also not appropriate there is a larger
discussion on cannabis legalization and
going ahead and outlying these without
having a larger solution would only send
users of this into the black market
which is an overall harm
that that is actually attached to
another bill as well so it's something
we'll be looking at regardless
but the biggest issue is who are we
talking about here
we have patients that have different
different medical problems they're
serious
a lot of them are seeing a doctor an
optometrist podiatrist a naturopath or a
dentist who cannot certify them for the
therapeutic cannabis patient program
so if you have glaucoma with elevated
intraocular pressure one of those that
we have specifically called out as an
indication for therapeutic cannabis
you can't have your optometrist
recommend you you need to go find
another doctor we have 89 patients how
many would we have if this was allowed
and how many people are just going to
the black market or crossing straight
lines
gets worse when we talk about serious
pain
podiatrists and dentists deal with
people who have failed surgery and are
still in severe intractable pain
opioids are an option cannabis should be
an option too
cannabis is no cure-all but it's an
option for some patients and it
shouldn't be denied because of who they
see on a regular basis
it is discrimination to exclude
naturopaths a dentist optometrist and
podiatrists while Physicians advanced
practice registered nurses and physician
Physicians assistants are allowed to
certify a patient for cannabis let's fix
this by voting yes
this also impacts kids
they need two providers to sign off and
the language says one needs to be a
pediatrician
the way it's interpreted today is that
your pediatric oncologist counts as a
pediatrician
your pediatric neurologist if you have
seizures counts as a pediatrician
because they looked at our legislative
intent my fear here is that if we vote
this down without a committee of
conference that's going to be harder to
have that flexibility and we have kids
that have epilepsy severe autism cancer
PTSD severe pain spinal cord injury and
traumatic brain injury that are on the
therapeutic cannabis program right now
anybody have a guess as to how many kids
under 18 are on this program
it's eight
and there are
let's see and there are 10 18 year olds
who are on the program
this limiting factor around
pediatricians when a lot of these
severely complex kids don't have a
pediatrician because quaint frankly
they're working with their pediatric
oncologist to make it to their 18th
birthday is yet another hurdle
this is a very very important underlying
bill that we should not let the Senate
hold hostage
we will uphold the house position of
working through bail reform this fall
and we will not let the Senate Bill 252
section pass
looking for input as well on these
synthetic cannabinoids I see a big
problem with outlawing it right now we
can talk about it in the overall scheme
but if today we do not approve this
request for a committee of conference it
is on us to deny this access to patients
and to continue an injustice against
these providers
I ask for your support to go to the
committee of conference so we can stand
firm and protect these people thank you
Mr Speaker
and I request a division vote
the question is whether do not concur
request committee a conference on House
Bill 610 and this is a division vote
members please secrecy it's
here
the questions whether to non-concur
request Committee of conference on House
Bill 610 and this is a division vote
representative Weber is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry
an excellent bill for all the reasons
that you've heard
but I also know that there are already
providers who can certify and I know
that
cannabis treatment for children has many
reasons why
certification may not be the best option
even though uh
even though it would it might be easier
with these other providers
and if I know
that so so the point I was trying to
make is that
um there may be other reasons for this
low numbers of kids on the program
if I understand that bail reform will be
taken up
comprehensively thoughtfully and
carefully and with the input of all
stakeholders which is not what happens
in a committee of conference
and finally if I know that this is a
practice by the Senate
my apologies by the body on the other
side of the wall
that most of us deplore and rewarding
bad behavior is not a way to get bad
behavior to go away what I now vote know
on the proposed Committee of conference
so a better motion could be made thank
you
representative Roy is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know
that indeed the criminal justice
committee will deal with the bail issues
over the summer
and further Mr Speaker if I know we
should discourage the practice of
committee shopping by the other body
but I also know that the prime bill is
worthy of saving and
there are people that need this
for their eyesight it's definitely worth
saving we already passed it why would we
throw it with a baby with the bathwater
at this point Mr Speaker would I then
vote for the committee of conference so
we can strip it back to the bill that we
passed and move forward from there thank
you
the question is whether a non concur
request Committee of conference in House
Bill 610 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press thread voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
of all members presence and an
opportunity to vote
good thing I asked
now of all members present at an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
194 in the affirmative 175 and the
negative the Motions adopted
on behalf of the house the chair
appoints Representatives Leon Roy Weber
and Palmer to the committee of
conference
representative Kenny is recognized for a
lunchtime announcement
thank you Mr Speaker my name is Cam
Kenny I'm one of the co-chairs of the
progressive caucus on behalf of the
board we'd like to invite members of the
progressive caucus
um right over across the street at the
Upham Walker house for a luncheon it's
sponsored by Granite State progress and
it is catered by the work so come on
over and have some good discussions
thank you
representative D Simone is recognized
for a lunchtime announcement
let's let's let them be heard
thank you Mr Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues
the owls
why thank you are an organization it is
the order of women legislators and we
assist women in all walks of their lives
to become more successful either in
politics or everyday life
we are having a lunch meeting in the
Webster room upstairs as soon as we
break for lunch I would
I appreciated if the women from both
sides of the aisle and the men from both
sides of the aisle would join us for
lunch so that we can talk about what we
can do next year to assist all women and
men in becoming more successful thank
you
and representative gerhardt is
recognized for lunchtime announcement
thank you speaker just a quick
announcement before the legislative golf
tournament on June 26th at 7 30 in the
morning there'll be a defend the guard
rally for the upcoming legislation
so the bill is very simple saying we
cannot send the New Hampshire National
Guard overseas unless Congress does its
job and declares war I think it's very
important keep our neighbors here so if
you guys can show up I appreciate it
just to add some bipartisan tip to this
it's a very important thing we should
not be sending our troops to war unless
our representative democracy has
approved it no Executives should be
sending our troop to war without our
approval and join us to rally for that
before the golf tournament that day
thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah
the house will be in recess until 1 30.
recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate occurs with the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the Senate
has the concurrence of the house house
bill 467 relative to public playground
accessibility
representative Lynn Circa moves that we
non-concur request a committee of
conference
representative kutab is recognized to
speak against the motion
let's settle down the house will be in
order the member has a right to be heard
thank you Mr Speaker
the Senate amendment to House Bill 467
just clarifies that this is only for new
playgrounds
House Bill 467
provides accessible Pathways to public
playgrounds
this is a civil rights issue everybody
should be able to use public places
we have little kids
who cannot access the playground
grandparents who cannot access it to
take their grandkids out to play
and for me one of the most heartbreaking
things to hear
was the little kids at recess
who are in a wheelchair and forced to
sit and watch the rest of their
classmates play
while they themselves were unable to
play
we owe it to these kids to do right by
them and make sure that they can use the
playgrounds just like they can use any
other public building
we're all taxpayers we all pay taxpayer
dollars
we should make sure that every single
person can benefit that every single
person has a reasonable
way of accessing
public amenities
so I ask you to please vote no
on this request for committee a
conference so that another more sensible
motion can be made that supports
children thank you
representative McMahon is recognized to
speak against the motion
sorry about that Mr Speaker
thank you very much and good afternoon
fellow colleagues I rise in support of
not supporting a committee of conference
the the issue that we have before us
here
is accessibility for all our all our
families and and citizens regardless of
age
when I bring to the table here is one
thing that we have led the nation on in
my view and I've been here
for quite a while I'm not old but I'm
aggressively mature is the
I hope that that's a good thing
is that we have led the nation in home
and community-based care and a big part
of that is our parents taking care of
their handicapped physically handicapped
and times mental mental challenges as
well children and young adults and also
parents
and what used to take place prior to
1990 when it was a requirement to
consider
adjusting handicapped accessibility to
public buildings this one included was
the Ada the American Disabilities Act
and had some amendments since since then
the last one in 2008 and providing for
reasonable reasonable is the term access
what we have about Playgrounds taking
place which this bill is focused on and
it's for the as the sponsor previously
indicated is what's coming to be built
is that it provides that access
for those with with physical handicaps
and and right now in how playgrounds are
built and I'm one who did that in my
town as well was uh providing a strong
not pavement per se but an ability where
wheelchairs
Walkers and also canes can be utilized
without causing a trip Hazard and when
we have the opportunity for young people
to participate with their friends who
are able-bodied but they can be right
there with them that builds up a
camaraderie of support not just with
their families their friends but with
their town because everyone is working
with Cooperative collaboration to
achieve consensus and that is to help
each other
so when I'm looking here is to ask that
we are asking not to support the vote
for committee of conference so that we
can move this opportunity forward for
future planning of these projects
and to get done in one of my lines that
I use that let's do it while we're young
and that's that's do it today thank you
very much thank you Mr Speaker
representative ball is recognized speak
against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
having accessible Pathways and
playgrounds so those both young and old
can access the playground equipment has
been a federal law since March 15 2012.
the Ada 2010 standards requires an
accessible path from the building or
parking lot to the edge of the play area
and again
an accessible path from the edge of the
play area to the play equipment
currently many New Hampshire playgrounds
use compressed wood chips to create
these pathways
however using compressed wood chips to
create Pathways requires routine
maintenance to keep the chips compacted
imagine the disappointment so many New
Hampshire families feel when they arrive
at a playground for an afternoon of fun
only to find that the chips have been
kicked around and loosened to the point
that a family member in a wheelchair
using a walker a cane or crutches cannot
Traverse the now uneven path
as a primary caretaker to my mother who
is confined in a wheelchair I can tell
you that trying to include my mother in
our family's outdoor activities required
a herculation effort
New Hampshire is better than this
in New Hampshire we believe in
supporting our friends and family with
Mobility challenges by assuring we
provide equal access to all New
Hampshire has to offer this includes fun
a fun-filled day at our public
playgrounds
given New Hampshire's aging population
and the number of grandparents who are
now primary caregivers to their
grandchildren and or provide daycare for
their grandchildren we cannot ignore a
situation that is not working for them
whether it be pushing a stroller being
in a wheelchair using a walker a cane or
crutches or assisting a child with a
Mobility challenge New Hampshire's
caregivers need accessible Pathways in
our public playgrounds made from
resilient solid surface materials and
not a loose fill or aggregate
it is well past time for New Hampshire
to take proactive measures to assure all
those with Mobility challenge have equal
access to every piece of playground
equipment every time they arrive at a
playground
please vote no to the committee of
conference
and then vote Yes to concur so everyone
young and old can enjoy equal access to
our public playgrounds thank you
representative Donnelly is recognized
speak against the emotional
representative Donnelly
all right
representative turcott as when turcott
has recognized speaking support of the
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
let's start off
making it Crystal Clear there is nothing
that prevents a town or a city
from doing what this bill is asking to
do
what we are doing here is trying to
maintain a consistent policy in the
municipal and County government
committee and I will speak a little bit
more on that in a second
the Ada already has significant
requirements for playgrounds in fact the
summary summary document for playgrounds
alone is 40 pages that's the summary
document
this bill would state
would have the state mandate above and
beyond
what the already expensive ADA
requirements contain
now you I'm sure all of you are going to
remember three bills that came out of
Municipal and County government this
year
that were state mandates thrown down
onto towns each one
failed here in a large bipartisan manner
one was four units on a single family
law one was rent control and the other
one we actually tabled talking about two
accessory dwelling units
we should never support state mandates
on municipalities that have the ability
to zone or in this case increase or add
to the ADA requirements
speaking to that last point
I've already opened up this test speech
talking about there's nothing
that prevents a town from installing
materials as this bill would have them
do there's nothing that requires or
prevents them from putting that on there
now
if a town wants rubber or mats or
whatever they want to do they can do
that
we don't need the state telling them to
do that
it's our belief that we do not need a
bureaucrats adding red tape to making
these playgrounds more costly than the
Ada's already requires
primary concern of one of the sponsors
was that a town that they were an
occupant went and built a playground
based on the contractor's recommendation
and after completion they realized it
was not perfect so they would have to do
some more work or potentially redo it
now my points to this are one caveat
mtor
why did the town elected officials not
do their research
either on their own regarding what was
required
or on the contractors that sold them
on putting in whatever they put in we
only heard that one side of the story
however
the main focus of the proposed Bill
appears to be
we have to require rubber matting
because we couldn't or didn't do our
homework so we need the New Hampshire
Nanny state to mandate beyond the Ada
again
there's nothing that prevents a town or
a city from putting down whatever
material they want already without
adding a mandate
so in summary this bill contains
excessive bureaucratic overreach that
would require regulation that already
exceed the comprehensive ADA rules it
creates potentially expensive State
imposed mandates
that can already be considered
and we do not need
the potential for towns or cities
looking at this expensive Edition
mandated by the state to the point where
they decide maybe we don't even build a
playground so for that reason I would
ask that you non-concur so we can have a
committee a conference there is a
language that has been proposed that
would at least inform
towns through the rsas that they should
consider alternatives but it would not
mandate those Alternatives thank you Mr
Speaker
representative bill Boys recognized
speak against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker and Mr Speaker
through you to my distinguished
colleagues of the New Hampshire General
Court
I rise in opposition to the
non-concurrents of house bill 467.
I will not be redundant in my testimony
to you as our esteemed colleagues have
made the eloquent argument against
non-concurrents
what I would say to you in opposition to
non-confurrence is this
we are all American citizens we cherish
the pillars of our Declaration of
Independence which is life liberty and
pursuit of happiness
as legislators we've taken
the oath of our office to preserve
protect and defend our constitutions
we cherish our right to self-govern
but these devotions to the ideals of
freedom and democracy are the keys to
our Civic responsibilities as
distinguished members of the general
court then isn't it the key to our
ebulent Humanity that include the
Devotion to the tacit agreement that we
will leave our children with something
better from which we received
I voted for House Bill 467 because I
believed it would be made better and
easier for all granted State children
and their families to access playgrounds
in the future
voting against non-concurrents will
permit all playground participants to
freely congregate and recreate in these
accessible areas I sincerely ask that
you vote against non-concurrents so that
another vote may be made thank you and
thank you Mr Speaker
representative DeSimone is recognized
speak against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues
I am the grandmother who has gone to the
playground with my grandchildren
using a cane
and found it very difficult to Traverse
I am the grandmother who looks forward
to a better future for my grandchildren
and for any child who would love to go
and play with their friends and their
peers and be able to get into
the playground to have that fun it's an
important right of passage
I look forward to a better future and to
vote
any other way on this bill does not
provide a better future for the kids and
the grandparents and the parents who we
use canes
wheelchairs
or any other apparatus to get in and to
get out
of a playground nothing is worse than to
see a child
in a wheelchair sitting at the edge of a
playground because they can't make it to
the swing that specifically made for
them to use
I pray that you make the right decision
when you vote thank you
and thank you Mr Speaker
representative borders is recognized
speak against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker I don't want to
reiterate everything my previous
colleagues prior to me said but this is
an extent you can't hear oh sorry
um I don't want to repeat what my fellow
colleagues said before me but this is a
common sense measure
um if you have two children and one's
handicapped you have to leave your
handicapped child at the entrance of a
playground because they can't go play
with the other child it's just it's just
common sense to pass this bill and I
appreciate your time thank you Mr
Speaker
representative priest has recognized
speak against the motion
representative Prius great time
speaker
I'm here to speak in opposition to the
motion for a committee of conference for
HB 467.
children with disabilities
aren't someone else's problem
they are our children
our grandchildren our nieces and nephews
they're the children of our next door
neighbors
we are responsible for their care
in fact in 2021 there were over 12
000 children in New Hampshire with some
forms of physical disabilities
these children and their caretakers
constantly face barriers enjoying their
fundamental human rights and inclusion
in our communities
children with disabilities are
overlooked their capacities are
underestimated and their needs are given
a low priority
when this bill was presented at the
municipal and County government
committee
the ketamini members heard testimony
that there were many obstacles for
disabled people
and their obstacles are found in all of
our communities
they are reflected in policies
regulations created by governments some
of the obstacles are physical for for
example barriers to public buildings
transportation and recreational
facilities
this bipartisan Bill seeks to amend RSA
155 by adding a new section requiring
any playground
in use on or after January 2024
have
accessible Pathways made of compositive
surfacing and similar solid surface
material
this bill would complement the federal
Americans Disabilities Act
improving accessibility will make
playgrounds and Parks more inclusive and
welcoming to all children and their
caretakers especially those with
disabilities
in addition adding Pathways made of
these materials will relieve towns of
the need to replace less accessible
materials periodically and save money
over time
in the municipal committee as well as
this house here we both voted
to approve HB 467.
the changes that our friends on the
other side of the wall has only improved
the bill
if my fellow Representatives believe as
I do
that New Hampshire State constitutional
article one that all men are born
equally and this includes those children
with disabilities and their caretakers
then we will do the right thing and vote
down this motion of Committee of
conference
and press the red button so another
motion
to concur with this bill can be made
thank you very much
representative Powers recognized to
speak in support of the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I ask you to support the
motion on House Bill 467 to non-concur
so that the bill can go to a committee
of conference to be clear this is not
about accessibility it's about an
unfunded mandate
the part of the Senate amendment that
changed the description of the material
mandated for playground Pathways is
highly problematic for a number of
reasons
first the term resilient in reference to
a solid surface material is improperly
used which creates confusion
resiliency indicates the ability of a
material to absorb a fall and reduce
severity of injury specifically a head
injury a resilient material is one that
meets impact attenuation industry
standards
typically this applies to material
materials used under playground
equipment not on pathways
to be clear material standards for
accessible accessible pathways are
established to evaluate firmness and
stability of the material not its
resiliency so this wording is clearly a
problem
second
solid surface material that is not a
loose fill or aggregate is a further
concern
this language outright prohibits the use
of other acceptable surfacing materials
that are both ADA Compliant and meat
ASTM 1951 standards moreover this
language mandates the use of a single
material and it's an unfunded mandate
notably materials
material experts that I spoke with agree
that the only resilient solid surface
material that is not a loose fill or an
aggregate is in fact solid rubber or
rubber composite surfacing
so in effect the Ascend the Senate
Amendment complicates the problematic
language
third this single material specified by
this mandate has serious implications
since rubber surfacing has a number of
problems and concerns associated with it
poured in place rubber surfacing is
extremely expensive to install and
maintain over time and with exposure to
the elements cracks can form on the
surface allowing moisture to penetrate
to the subsurface below once the crack
has formed it slowly worsens through
seasonal freezing and thawing Cycles
combined with the effects of erosion and
oftentimes aggravated by vandalism
eventually the surface is undermined to
the point that a portion of it implodes
requiring a very expensive repair by a
qualified Technic technician
then there is the prohibitive cost
Factor associated with the installation
of rubber surfacing for example for 200
square feet of solid rubber surfacing
the cost of materials in labor is 25
dollars per square foot or fifty
thousand dollars total compared to three
dollars and 75 cents per square foot or
seventy five hundred dollars for
engineered wood fiber which is Ada and
ASTM 1951 standard compliant material
rubber surfacing is nearly seven times
more expensive compared to an acceptable
alternate material
such an extreme cost difference for the
mandated rubber surfacing would
unnecessarily drive up the cost of new
playgrounds causing projects to be
scaled back or even tabled because they
are simply too expensive to build
ironically rather than providing more
accessible playgrounds this amendment
will most likely end up having the
opposite effect resulting in fewer new
playgrounds it's also worth noting that
rubber surface surfacing is a
petroleum-based non-renewable man-made
foreign product rubber surfacing is not
a green product rubber surfacing is not
biodegradable and it ends up in our
landfills there are also serious health
and safety concerns associated with
rubber surfacing under certain weather
conditions such as long sun exposure or
extreme heat situations it's possible
for children to sustain thermal burns
from the rubber surfacing additionally
there are a number of ongoing safety
studies
which may result in future Federal
Regulations requiring the removal and
replacement of rubber materials on
playgrounds lastly
by placing in into Statute in
unnecessary
expensive unfunded mandate for
playground design and construction above
and beyond what is already required by
federal law for accessibility the
amended Bill constrains local control in
decision making which in turn negatively
affects local spending and Taxation
therefore I urge my fellow colleagues to
support the motion by voting yes so that
this bill can go to a committee of
conference thank you Mr Speaker and I
asked for a division vote does the
member yield for a question
remember yields you may inquire
thank you Mr speaker thank you for
taking my question isn't it true that
according to our state constitution
unfunded mandates are against the state
constitution
that would be correct
question before the house is whether to
non-concur request committee a
conference on House Bill 467.
okey-dokey representative Len circot
requests a roll calls that's official
yep it is this will be a roll call vote
question is whether do not concur
request committee conference on House
Bill 467 representative Grossman is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this is a civil rights
issue about freedom
and access for all Granite Staters to
enjoy our public playgrounds regardless
of age or mobility issues
if I know that this is already federal
law under the Americans with
Disabilities standards for accessible
design has bipartisan support and
support from the New Hampshire Municipal
Association
and if I believe the deeply personal
testimony that spanned all ages
political parties and included a wide
array of Mobility
abilities that would benefit from this
legislation
did I invite you to support the
bipartisan legislation and press the red
button to ensure that all Granite
Staters have the freedom
to access our public playgrounds with
their loved ones and so another motion
can be made thank you
representative Powers recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
the law for playground pathways
mandating the use of a single expensive
material with known negative
characteristics in prohibiting the use
of other ADA Compliant materials fails
to make more playgrounds more accessible
and if I know that the bill as amended
is imprudent in or in an unfunded
overreaching State mandate that strips
away local control and will
unnecessarily drive up the cost of any
future playground projects resulting in
fewer not more accessible playgrounds
across the granite state
and if I know that towns can already
install solid surface material if they
want to there's absolutely nothing
stopping them what I now vote Yes to
support
the motion to non-concur and request a
committee of conference by pushing the
green button so that the bill language
can be properly addressed in a committee
of conference thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether a non-concur
request to committee a conference on
House Bill 467 and this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
Perez
represent Perez
this doesn't tell thank you
representative rich
of all members presence and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
161 in the affirmative 199 and a
negative the motion fails
for what reason does a member rise
I Rise to make a motion to concur
representative moves that the house
concur are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk for
further Senate messages Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house and the
passage of falling entitled bill with
Amendment the passage of which amendment
the Senate acid concurrence of the house
house bill 281. relative to least cost
integrated resource plans of utilities
Municipal hosts for purposes of limited
electrical energy producers the cost of
compliance with disclosure of electric
renewable portfolio standards repealing
the Energy Efficiency and sustainable
energy board and procedures for energy
facilities citing by the site evaluation
committee
representative moves that the house
concur
representative McGee is recognized to
speak against the motion
arise today to ask for your support
in opposing the motion to concur on HB
this bill started out as a bad Bill and
it ended up worse
it deletes the state's consumer
protection statute that requires
utilities to provide a leased cost
integrated resource plan to our
Regulators every five years
plans help make sure the utilities do
not saddle rate payers with stranded
costs on their electric bills
this statute requires quote an
assessment of short and long-term
environmental economic and energy price
and Supply impacts on the state end
quote
and a number of other requirements but
I'm not going to go into them here
if we no longer require
energy analysis uh that New Hampshire
currently has in law how do we keep the
utilities accountable for how they spend
our money
lease cost energy planning is in statute
for a reason
we agreed to update some language
but then this bill came along to throw
the baby out with the bath water and
that will lead to granted Staters in the
future asking us how did we get here
so there was opposition to HB 281 before
it went over to the other side of the
wall
once there it was morphed into a
Frankenstein
it is now five bills attempting to pass
the house as one
most of these bills had distinct
opposition
one was a good bill that was taken
Hostage to sweeten the idea of Passage
we lose more than we gain so I ask you
to understand that fact as legislators
over and over those of us who were
closely looking at this Frankenstein
came to the same conclusion
just because they can do it doesn't mean
we should let them
two of the bills that are being included
in HB 281 uh our monster Bill were
retained in committee so they have not
been before the house they were pulled
out of retained status and incorporated
into this Frankenstein
so they skipped the hard part of the law
making and just decided to cut to
pressing us for our votes
the last piece of this Frankenstein
monster is the last bill from stne that
you voted down already today so I guess
it's a second bite at the Apple we were
told that its purpose was transparency
but as amended it's actually worse it
has the department of energy now
calculating the average renewable
portfolio standard charge on an average
bill and then they make the utilities
print that number on every bill at the
end of the year
for the entire year
and the charge will either be more than
what you actually paid or less than what
you actually paid but it will not be
what you actually paid
so the law on transparency should not
make your bill clear as mud
if you agree that this is no way to pass
laws
then I ask you to understand also that a
committee of conference cannot fix what
is wrong with this bill
or bills
HB 281 is a Frankenstein please push the
red button to vote against concurrence
so that a more villager-friendly Bill
I'm sorry motion can be made and a
requested division vote
representative versus recognized
speaking support of the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
earlier this morning I spoke about House
Bill 139
and how its original contents
were so attractive to the
colleagues of ours on the other side of
the wall that they put it in another
bill
well this is the bill they put it into
house bill 281.
and that language expands a program
called Municipal host net metering
this is a program that allows
municipalities to build Renewable Energy
Systems
but right now it restricts those systems
to the music municipality itself it
can't go outside the boundaries of the
municipality
the language that the Senate put that
the body on the other side of the wall
put into this bill
removes those Municipal boundaries this
will allow municipalities to band
together
and build Renewable Energy Systems of
three to five megawatts if they so
choose
now why is that important
yesterday the mayor of
Nashua
and the mayor of Keene
wrote an op-ed
saying that expanding Municipal host net
metering is a big win for New Hampshire
they advocated for the passage of house
bill 281.
many other
environmental Advocates have also
advocated for the passage of House Bill
because of Municipal host net metering
but our colleagues on the other side of
the wall
made this bill even more important to
pass
one of the most important new features
of this bill
is a reform of the operations of the
site evaluation committee
what the amendment from the other side
of the wall does
is it asserts the authority of
individual state agencies in the
permitting process
it makes the department of energy the
Monitor and enforcer of certificate
requirements concerning the construction
of energy projects
and it gives to the department the power
to Levy fines and take other enforcement
actions
it allows the department to adopt rules
and furtherance of its monitoring and
enforcement responsibilities
it requires that all orders granting or
denying a site certificate summarize
public reactions to the project
and it clarifies the Department's
authority to fund its site evaluation
actions
now this is important legislation right
now we have a dysfunctional site
evaluation committee
and we've got new energy projects that
are coming down the pike that are going
to have to go before the site evaluation
committee and without reforms like this
those projects will get bogged down in a
process that could delay them for years
And Delay means increased costs
now in addition to
these major changes that HB 281 makes it
retains the original
language of the bill
which was to eliminate something called
the least cost integrated resource
planning statute
now back in the days when utilities own
their own generation plants
this was an important part of the
planning process
you wouldn't want to
misjudge what your future electricity
needs were going to be and build more a
bigger power plant than you need
or conversely not build enough of a
power plant to supply that need
so resource planning was important back
when the utilities owned generation
but they don't anymore
we fully divested
the ownership of generation from the
utilities
as of 2018.
so this statute is no longer necessary
it doesn't do what some people think it
does
it doesn't
allow proposals to modernize the grid
it doesn't require the utilities
to go out and buy power from the
cheapest source available
none of that is part of resource
planning
what resource planning does do does it
cost a lot of money for the utilities to
write these plans
and they pass those costs along to us
and it costs a lot of money for the puc
and the department of energy to review
those plans
which ends up costing taxpayer money
so this absolute stat obsolete statute
has been removed according to the Senate
Amendment
pardon my
forgetfulness and saying Senate when I
mean the people on the other side of the
wall
in addition to
removing the least least cost integrated
resource planning statute
which reduces the size of administrative
government
this bill also replaces the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board with a smaller and more
streamlined process within the
department of energy
which further reduces the size and the
cost of government
so House Bill 281
is a winner as amended by our friends on
the other side of the ball
is a winner
on five counts
and I urge you to vote to concur
with my motion to concur
thank you Mr Speaker does the member
yield for a question yes
I'm Harrington you may inquire thank you
Mr Speaker and thank you member for
taking my question
um just would you agree that the way the
electric uh utility rates are actually
set is by going out for competitive bid
every six months and that's how the
default Service rates are actually set
and Lease cost planning has no effect on
that whatsoever
correct least cost integrated resource
planning has no effect on what we pay
for our electricity
on a day-to-day basis I also forgot to
mention
that
the Senate also put into this bill
House Bill 251 which we actually
rejected a little while ago
but the fact remains that
statute
still contains a requirement
that the department of energy lists the
cost of compliance with the renewable
portfolio portfolio standard on your
electric bill every year
all this bill HB 28251 did was add a
estimated yearly dollar figure to the
bill
for additional transparency
so that is another reason that this bill
is worthy of
concurrence thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 281
representative McKee's requested a
division vote members please take your
seats
uh
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 281
representative Corman is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that even though
the utilities don't generate electricity
they still have to build resources
because after all it does have to get to
your house one way or another
and if I know that the underlying Bill
HB 281 allows the utilities to build
resources at more than the least cost
which would leave rate payers on the
hook for the excess costs
and if I know that the other body tacked
on four other house bills onto this one
and two of these tacked on bills were
retained in committee so that they have
not been discussed in the house as a
body
and if I know that despite that we've
heard that some Mayors are supporting
this bill and actually some
environmental groups are the bad parts
of this bill outweigh the good and in
fact there are environmental groups that
recognize that and are against this bill
then Mr Speaker would I press the red
button and vote against concurring with
the Amendments that turned this into a
Frankenstein bill
representative versus recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
House Bill 281
includes an important expansion of
Municipal host net metering
that is wanted by the mayor of Nashua
the mayor of Keene and many other
renewable energy Advocates without our
state
if I know for example
that those Mayors said recently and I
quote
the evidence is clear that HB 281 will
do far more good than harm for our
state's environment and economy
let's take this opportunity to expand
energy Independence for New Hampshire
cities and towns while offsetting
hundreds of millions of pounds of carbon
pollution every year for decades to come
and Mr Speaker if I also know that this
bill contains other important important
reforms to the site evaluation committee
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
this bill
reduces costs
and administrative overhead for our
utilities and reduces administrative
burden for our regulatory bodies
when I now place the green button to
vote to concur on this Bill thank you
the question is whether to concur with
the Senate on House Bill 281 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
represent Bernie
hello members present had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
176 in the affirmative 180 in the
negative the motion fails
for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I move non-concur and request
a committee of conference
representative votes moves a thousand
non-concurrent request to committee a
conference
okay you ready for the what
who did
I'm sorry
representative Weber requests a division
vote this will be a division vote
members take receipts
the question is whether or not
concurrent request a committee a
conference on House Bill 281
representative McGee is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
if I know that this bill has more bad in
it than good and if I know that the good
in the bill was put there expressly to
split us on whether or not we should let
this bill go through for the good that
it would do in order to get
aspects of the law that we would not
normally vote in favor of into law
without due consideration and without
even coming before this body
for consideration it
then would I now please press
the red button and again
not let this go through on Committee of
conference because as we all know the
committee of conference process means
that whoever controls who's on the
committee of conference ends up with the
outcome that they would like
thank you
representative is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
speaker if I know that cities and towns
all across New Hampshire
would like the opportunity
to use the municipal post net metering
program to lower their energy costs
and if I also know that there is not a
bill in existence that couldn't be
improved
with
further negotiation
when I press the green button to support
this motion thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether to non-confur
request committee conference on House
Bill 281 this is division vote if you're
in favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
and I voted
for what reason does remember us
I'm sorry let's step up hold on to make
a motion
the house bill 281 Committee of
conference on behalf of the house chair
points Representatives Vos Doug Thomas
Harrington and McGee
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to reprint
the debates on HB 467 in the permanent
Journal
on which bill
467.
without objection the debate on House
Bill 467 will be placed in the permanent
Journal
the chair recognized
the chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house in the adoption of the
amendment to the Fallen entitled bill
Senate from the house Senate Bill 70
relative to the establishment of an
election information portal and relative
to the purchase of election equipment
and request a committee of conference
the president on the part of the Senate
has appointed as members of said
committee Senators gray Murphy and
Perkins quoka
representative very moves that we exceed
representative Berry moves that we
exceed are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the Motions adopted
chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption of the
amendment to the following title bill
Senate from the house Senate bill one
five seven relative to election Audits
and requests a committee of conference
the president on the part of the Senate
has appointed as members of said
Committee of conference Senators gray
Birdsall and Susie
representative Berry moves that we
exceed are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye all those
proposed name
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption of the
amendment to the following title bill
Senate from the house Senate Bill 61
relative to surface water setbacks for
landfills and request a committee of
conference the president on the part of
the Senate has appointed as members of
said Committees of conference Senators
evard Pearl and Waters
representative Aaron moves that we
exceeds the request are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed name
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the Senate refuses to concur with the
house and the adoption of the amendment
to the following entitled Bill center
from the house Senate Bill 147 relative
to the board of dental examiners and
requests a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said Committee
of conference Senators Innis Carson and
Perkins Cuoco representative
representative Carol McGuire moves a
thousac seats with a request you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
all those opposed name the eyes have it
and the Motions adopted still recognizes
the clerk Mr Speaker the Senate refuses
to concur with the house and the
adoption of the amendment to the
following title bill Senate from the
house Senate Bill 203 relative to the
board of manufactured housing and
requested Committee of conference
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said committee
Senators Abbas Bradley and Perkins quoka
yeah
representative Carol wire refuses to
exceed and is recognized to speak to her
motion
thank you
thank you Mr Speaker this bill as it
came to us was the complete
restructuring of the board of
manufactured housing this is not a
regulatory board it's a quasi-judicial
board to hear complaints from members of
manufactured housing communities
we heard a great deal of opposition from
the members of the
these communities against this
restructuring they were violently
opposed
in fact the house position is at this
board which has taken no action since at
least 2019 is no longer necessary and
therefore it was deleted in house bill
2.
so
the committee decided there was no need
to restructure a board that we didn't
see any need
to continue and therefore we just
amended the bill to say let's keep their
history on the website for a few years
and in case some other organization
wants to take up
settling these problems
the so when the Senate asked for a
committee of conference
no one on the committee could think of
any reasonable compromise between our
position and theirs and since they don't
want our position and we don't want
their position we should just let this
bill quietly die thank you
the question is on the motion to refuse
to exceed are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
although suppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption of the
amendment to the following title bill
sent up from the house Senate Bill 207
relative to mental health critical
incident intervention and management and
relative to mental health practice and
request a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate as
appointed as members of said Committee
of conference Senators Pearl gendro and
Perkins Cuoco
representative McGuire moves that we
exceed to the Senate request are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those suppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption of the
amendment to the following title bill
center from the house Senate bill 14
relative to the use of game cameras and
relative to penalties for controlled
drug violations and request a committee
of conference the president on the part
of the Senate has appointed his members
of SEC committee conference Senators
Evart Pearl and Waters
representatives speline and Roy move
that the house exceeds of the Senate
request are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
and the Motions adopted
Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption he
Amendment to the Fallen entitled bill
Senate from the House of Representatives
Senate Bill 15 relative to the use of
tree strands and observation blinds and
request a committee of conference
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said committees
a conference Senators avard Pearl and
Waters
representative Spillane and Roy move
that the house exceeds
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those opposed nay
the eyes have it representative spleen
goalie Tudor and Carol Brown are
appointed to the committee conference
the chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption the
amendment to the following title bill
Senate from the house Senate Bill 47
establishing a commission to study
barriers to increase density of
residential development in New Hampshire
and request a committee of conference
the president on the part of the Senate
has appointed as members of said
committee Senators gray Murphy and
Perkins quoka
representative Len Circa moves up the
house exceed are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all that's supposed nay
the eyes have it
Representatives Lynn surcott
powerlesselles and majority are
appointed to the committee conference
the chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption of the
amendment to the following title bill
Senate from the house Senate Bill 78
relative to the subdivision regulations
on the completion of improvements and
requests a committee of conference the
president of the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said committee
Senators gray
Ennis and Susie
representative Lynn surcott moves a
thousand are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye all those
proposed nay the eyes have it on behalf
of the house the chair appoints
Representatives Landon turcott power
infantine and stavis to the committee of
conference chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate refuses to concur
with the house and the adoption the
amendment to the following title bill
center from the house SB 88 relative to
the annual dues paid by towns and cities
to town officers associations and
request a committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed as members of said committee
Senators gray Birdsall and Perkins Cuoco
representative Len circuit moves at the
house exceeds to the request are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
the eyes have it emotions adopted on
behalf of the house the sharepoints
representatives Len turcotte power Yokel
and majority to the committee conference
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the Senate refuses to concur with the
house and the adoption of the amendment
to the following entitled bill sent up
from the house Senate Bill 166 relative
to electric grid modernization and
requested Committee of conference the
president on the part of the Senate has
appointed his members of said committee
senators avar berzel and Waters
representative Vost moves that the house
exceeds of the request are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed name
the eyes have it motions adopted on
behalf of the house the chairpoints
representatives Vos Doug Thomas
Harrington and Corman to the committee
of conference
and the chair recognizes the clerk
either way
so bear with me for a minute here I made
a mistake I should have been reading the
names of the house conferees all along
and I did not so this will be quick
on Senate Bill 70 on behalf of the house
the sharepoint's representatives Barry
Lynn Brennan and quaylee to the
committee of conference
also the committee on Election law
Senate Bill 157 on behalf of the house
the share points Representatives Barry
landmirhead and boehm
Senate Bill 61
on behalf of the house the chair
appoints Representatives Aaron Bixby
Megan Murray and Davis
Senate Bill 147 on behalf of the child
the house the chair appoints
Representatives Carol McGuire Stewart
Juliet Smith and true
Senate Bill 207 on behalf of the house
the chair appoints Representatives
goalie grota it's and Simon did I got
that right
and Senate bill 14.
on behalf of the House of sharepoints
Representative splame goalie Roy and
Harriet Guthrie thank you for your
patience
yes
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker in years
past there has been a link on the front
page of the general court website which
lists the committee of conference and
information about them do we know if
that link is going to be reinstated
because as of right now it has not
I'll let the clerk answer
or not
the answer is yes it will be live
at some point
yeah the clerk makes the valid point
that until this very day we didn't know
what all the Committees of conference
were going to be so far so they have to
do all that work
s the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for a
motion to adjourn from the early session
[Music]
thank you resolved at the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time and when it
adjourns today we meet at Thursday on to
meet at Thursday June 29th 2023
is there a time
at 10 A.M
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
we have announcements and unanimous
consents
representative Moffat is recognized for
an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker quick announcement
very quick uh quick update we've had a
great response so far for the
legislative Golf Classic which will be
on Monday June 26th Loudoun Country Club
uh the social up in the afternoon
everybody is welcome to come to the
social if you are not a golfer you're
welcome to buy a raffle ticket and if
you have any raffle items please feel
free to share earlier today you did hear
that there will be apparently a rally
that morning uh Loudoun country club
with regard to
hb229 that's the declaration of war
measure the activists are welcome to
stick around for the golf putting
contest it's only five bucks and finally
uh like by the way contact me or
representative Maggiore if you have any
raffle items or any questions we still
have room for a few more foursomes and
finally a happy birthday to Mr majority
leader thank you Mr Speaker
representative janvren is recognized for
unanimous consent
thank you Mr Speaker
as all of you in this room know I
suffered a pretty big loss in the last
couple weeks
but I wanted to come to the well
to express my gratitude for the words of
comfort
the messages I've gotten on Facebook
Twitter email
today outside many of you came to me and
offered your condolences the prayer this
morning and the prayer at our last house
session
told me that I'm in good company that
people in this house share my grief
but I wanted to talk a little bit about
what my son was to me
and I'm going to use the words of other
people not my words
in the last two weeks I've been around
the town of Seabrook where I live and
where my son called his home and where
he worked and played
and I went to Staples on Thursday of
this week I'm sorry Tuesday of this week
and one of my former co-workers came to
me to offer his condolences
and he said to me you know on Saturday
when this all occurred
your son was working at the town's
transfer station and he noticed that I
was having difficulty unloading my
trailer of trash
and
he came over immediately to help me that
was the type of boy that boy was
and during the process of offloading the
vehicle they he tore his bumper his
plastic bumper so my son says no problem
I'll be right back ran to his car
grabbed his Gorilla tape and came back
and not only did he just slap that
gorilla tape on there he got on his back
and slid under the car to make sure it
was really a fixed well
so that's the type of person my son was
and honestly the words that you folks
gave to me gave me Comfort and made it
so that I could come back here
and and do my job it's made the family
very very thankful for everybody in this
room including the folks down the hall
the few folks on the other side of the
wall
we had a celebration of life this last
Sunday and many members of this house
came thank you
I also had commissioners
and the colonel of the fish and game
came to get offers condolences
over 400 people and from the town of
Seabrook all the employees the town
officials thank you all and thank you to
the house and thank you Mr Speaker
for what reason doesn't remember us
I ask that the words of our good friend
be printed in the permanent journal
without objections so ordered and while
you're all still standing
let's do something went upgrade out and
be quiet and give them a moment of
silence please
representative germano is recognized for
unanimous consent
thank you Mr Speaker
this is my first term in the house it's
been that it is a tremendous honor to
serve with all of you we've had some
extraordinary accomplishments this
session recently we were reminded by the
speaker of the extraordinary example the
historic example we set in getting a
bipartisan budget passed and I think
that New Hampshire has led the way in in
showing the rest of the country that
Civility and and bipartisanship are not
dead
at the beginning of every session
together we pledge allegiance to the
flag
we pledge our allegiance to One Nation
the same Nation
our country is in for some difficult
months ahead the next 12 to 18 months or
so
I'm a historian and I think of the
ancient Chinese saying may you live in
interesting times a paraphrase President
Kennedy when he said it's a lot more
enjoyable to study interesting times
than it is to live through them
I hope that every member of this body in
the spirit of the bipartisanship and
civility that we've demonstrated
throughout this session
will join me in the coming months in
promoting that Civility and denouncing
unequivocally and publicly all calls
from wherever they come from all
candidates who make them regardless of
party for any kind of political violence
let us continue to show the rest of the
nation that that is the New Hampshire
way thank you
thank you
representative manager Puti is
recognized for unanimous consent
thank you Mr Speaker
Namaste to all of you
I'm here to share about the
international yoga day which is next
June 21st
International yoga day is celebrated on
21st of June every year to highlight the
importance of yoga and its benefit on
our mind and body
International yoga day is also
is a day to celebrate the Indian
practice of yoga and to raise awareness
about his importance started by prime
minister modi's initiative to pass a
resolution at UN in 2015. and it
coincidence it's a coincidence that
Prime Minister Modi will be in United
States next week Jan uh June 21st and
will be addressing the joint session and
this will be the ninth year of
international yoga day
the word yoga sorry the in 19 in 2023
this initiative aims to showcase the
transformative power of yoga in
fostering Global unity and harmonious
coexistence
aligning with the theme of yoga for the
vasudeva kutumbakam for the year which
means a global family
the word yoga is derived from the
Sanskrit root
meaning to join
or to yoke or to unite
as per yogic scriptures the practice of
yoga leads to the union of individual
consciousness
with that of universal consciousness
indicating a perfect harmony between the
mind and the body man and nature
human being and nature
in essence it is a non-verbal process
an inner Journey to the true center of
the Soul
which is the source of all happiness and
ultimately of union or
non-separativeness
the inner Journey follows many
concurrent paths
the pursuit of personal integrity
moral restraint
physical exercise
and breathing techniques
and I'm just going to focus on breathing
technique just for a brief moment
this is called the pranayama or freedom
to breathe
in Sanskrit means life force and IMR
means to extend
draw out restrain or control
breathing is a normal part of our life
and we often forget to pay attention to
it
when the breath is steady so is the mind
with breathing we can help to either
calm or excite the entire nervous system
when the breath becomes irregular and
unsteady so is our mental status
the ancient yogis measure the person's
lifespan not by years by the number of
his respiration
they believed that everyone is allocated
a fixed number of respirations in his or
her lifetime
breath is life life is breath
keep breathing and let us have freedom
to breathe breathing is fundamental to
human right and namaste
thank you
representative shewitt is recognized for
for unanimous consent
thank you Mr Speaker in recognition that
yesterday was Flag Day I'm going to
share with you a poem by John J Daly
called a salute to the flag
here's to the rid of it
there's not a threat of it no not a
shred of it in all the spread of it from
foot to head but Heroes bled for it
Precious Blood shed for it bathing it
red
here's to the white of it thrilled by
the sight of it who knows the right of
it through day and night
womanhoods care of it made manhoods Dare
for it
purity's prayer for it keeps it so white
here's to the blue of it Heavenly Hue of
it
Star-Spangled do of it sparkled anew
diadems Gloom for it States stand
Supreme for it Liberty's being for it
brightens the blue
here's to the whole of it stars stripes
and pull of it
body and soul of it
oh and the role of it
sun shining through
hearts in accord for it
thanking the lord for it red white and
blue
thank you
representative Osborne moves at the
house stands in recess for the purposes
of the introduction of Bill's enrolled
Bill amendments and rolled Bill reports
and receiving messages are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those posne the eyes have it the
Motions adopted
the house is in recess until Thursday
June 29 2023 at 10 A.M